so I want you to think about you're
about to buy a business what are some
things you'd be looking at if you're
buying a business no matter what the
business is you're gonna be looking at
the flow of traffic that's coming in in
flow that's coming in to traffic that's
coming in then you're going to look at
the existing customers that have already
bought from you then you're gonna look
at the B backs that keep coming back and
buying more so let me give you an
example that I mean by this let's just
say you want to buy a supermarket you'd
probably sit there and before you invest
into this market you're gonna see what
the traffic looks like from at this time
Mother Tuesday Wednesday Thursday Friday
that meant there's a lot of traffic
coming in then you're gonna see
customers that keep coming back then
you're gonna see people that are buying
more and more and more so there's an
opportunity to become B backs and
increases the value right so if you buy
a real estate business how many people
call into this real estate shop how many
people have already bought so calls
coming in how many bad and then from
there how many keep coming back to buy
some more real estate through your sell
through you that's the value of the
business right so now let's look at what
that means to you because what is the
best type of customers what is the most
important type of customers you can have
as an entrepreneur so here's a pipeline
of the sales flow right number one is
your pipeline that's up front then you
have your new customers new customers
could be cold market they could be warm
market they could be hot market what's
called market cold market could be
somebody you have no clue who it is so
you need to do a lot more of a better
job selling warm market is somebody that
was told about you this city already
kind of have an idea about who you are
and they're just coming to want to check
you out but they're easier to sell than
a cold market and then you have the hot
market a hot market is the meet to
customer the meet to customer says what
hey I want to have what she has gonna
have one as well I won't have exactly
what he but can I have one as wrong my
brother just bought this car can I have
one as well my father just bought this
can I have one as well I like to get the
same phone I'd like to get the same suit
I'd like to get the same sure I like to
get the same whatever okay great no
problem so cold warm hot market new then
you have your be back customers what is
the benefit of having a lot of be bad
customers be bad customers somebody
that's already bought from you
and so be back customer I want to buy it
again I want to buy it again I want to
buy a little bit more this realistic
could be I want to buy another house
from you I want to buy another house
form I wanted a my loan through you I
want to buy another insurance policy
from you I want to do my investment
through you I want to roll over my money
with you I want you to help in my social
media so why don't you you know give me
the software you know I want to get this
technology and I want to upgrade again
that's the be back customers so the me
back customer you always have an
opportunity to upsell you always have an
opportunity to up so if you think about
facebook wants be back fan pages because
on be back fan pages they have an
opportunity for you to keep rebooting
your post hypothetically Google AdWords
wants be back customers to be able to do
a new link to a website or video or
whatever because it's a be back customer
that they can upsell right they can
upsell no matter where you go this is
very important but then the most
important type of customer is a customer
that is a be bat that keeps giving you
referrals why is this so important
because the referrals they give is
adding to your pipeline and generally
the referrals they keep giving you is
hot referrals so it's a very easy sell
you're making with the hot market then
you are with a cold market so why is
this so important why are we talking
about so much on referral side again I
talked about this briefly on another
another video there are so many that
just chase knew that the easiest sale
you'll ever make is referral from your
existing be back customers that helps
you get more me to sales so in order to
get more me to sales that means you need
to make sure your existing customers are
being treated very well I did a video on
this a few weeks ago about the sales
cycle on what takes place but I didn't
get necessarily into the best type of a
customer these are by far the best type
of customers I want to give referrals to
because sometimes you'll have a custom
that I buy from you that you'll never
talk to again they don't want you to
call them they don't want you to talk to
them it was a one-time thing that
happened they don't want you to call
them it's not even the other way around
please stop calling us we got what we
wanted from you no problem but 99% at a
time is the person that sold the product
is not doing a good job
the products I want you to think about
about Google AdWords one of the things
Google is very good at is I'm so
impressed for Google it doesn't matter
what happens if I bought from Google one
time and I and I make a purchase from
Google AdWords I'm constantly getting
somebody emailing me somebody and I'm
your new rep I'd like to talk to you on
the phone I'm your new rep I like to
talk to you on the phone and see how we
can make your campaigns be more
successful in the future they do such a
great job with their existing book of
business and they upsell me they upsell
me because they call me so because they
upsell me and call me and I know my rep
is I know how to refer the rep to
somebody else that needs to know it and
I'm the credibility and so the pipeline
gets full for them again and by the way
we're talking Google the number one
search engine in the world that happens
to be one of the best at Phoenix oh my
gosh can you imagine that
so if Google is the number one search
engine in the world that sitting on God
knows how much cash in their account is
doing it that well and they already are
as successful as they are what is your
excuse on doing a great job with your
existing customers to help them become
be backs and help them become the best
referral source to you because the right
customer with the right amount of
referral source let me say if I'm a real
estate agent and I end up getting ten
customers that are very happy customers
that I make them be backs and they give
me referrals all the time I'm set with
ten great customers that give me
referrals matter of fact some will even
tell you five happy customers that give
you referrals on a monthly basis you're
set for the rest your couriers because
if five happy customers give you
referrals those five to give you five
more that's twenty five you take those
twenty five new customers and you make
them a happy customer then that twenty
five gives you another five to give you
five more Katti I mean you see what
happens you with the compounding efforts
of it so sales is a very easy game
entrepreneurship is a very easy game
it's a service game it's a treatment
game it's a memory game it's a taking
care of game if you do that part right
then your pipeline all of a sudden is so
filled with so many people that want to
do business with you and simply you take
them to do the same exact sales cycle
again to help them
to a happy customer that gives you again
more referral so if you got questions
about this comment on the bottom I will
get back to most your questions may take
some time because we are getting
thousands of messages now like we used
to be forwards hundreds now we're
getting thousands but we will get back
to you and if you're watching this video
on a complete different website you can
always come back to Patrick be David
comm for more content there you go and
then at the same time if you have not
subscribed to this channel let's see the
pillow please be sure to subscribe to
this channel by clicking clicking on the
bottom button here somewhere around here
and be sure to subscribe to the channel
that is the number one channel for
entrepreneurs on YouTube Michael Andrew
can you catch that one he caught it this
one this time last time he dropped today
eco it's got the nice little dance he's
doing for me anyways thanks for watching
everybody take care of bye-bye